Istanbul Ankara and Izmir are Tokyo's
three biggest cities and it said the
person who wins Istanbul wins the
country Tokyo's most populous province
is home to about 16 million people and
20 percent of all registered voters it's
where presidents Richard Thai Peruan
made his name as mayor but that job's
now held by the main opposition it's
also in control in Ankara the capital
and the coastal city of Izmir from the
last presidential election in 2018 all
of these provinces in yellow voted for
erdogan and turkey a central
conservative Heartland helping him stay
in power with more than half of the vote
but some of those strongholds in the
Southeast could now be in question with
these 11 provinces badly affected by the
earthquakes in February the head of the
Supreme election Council said that at
least one million voters there aren't
expected to cast their ballots because
they've been displaced by the disaster
let's head further south east where most
of the Kurdish population is
concentrated and the main pro-kurdish
party under the green left Banner has
thrown its support behind erwan's
presidential rival Kamal Khalid the last
region to mention isn't even in Turkey
it's Western Europe where the vast
majority of the Turkish diaspora live
and it's 3.4 million registered voters
about half of those have cast ballots in
this year's elections a record turnout
but some violence has been reported at
polling stations analysts suggest that
illustrates the polarization of the
Turkish electorate